[Music]
this is Silvia I sell beer so again Tea
Party oke right
I wasn't smarter
[Music]
in your hand let's say my gob of milk
spicy in a cup made out of wood you know
we work with dynamic things have you
been any other one Messina double pillar
I do all the Kapiti machine you haven't
either but what I am interested in do
you have a particular favorite fast
photograph stop that you that you
particularly like any one of the
photographs on the wall like I've got a
daughter here a granddaughter and to
tool and daughters my wife a
great-granddaughter ok can you say which
ones favorite you can't can you
did you see my great-granddaughter here
year 1 year old she's she's right in the
middle of it here but she's drinking a
cider
is that the baby in the stroller turn
over to the children how many years have
you been here professor
I came here in 1926 to spend one year
and got stuck I am unable get out
do you attribute anything in particular
to your good fortune in photography
well my lucky land right in the middle a
place where it was needed you're very
fortunate if you land a good place where
there's something that you want to do
and you like to do there any area
photography that you haven't delved into
as much as you like it's a big field I
just work at high-speed area that's all
I do just a little bit but I'm reading
an electrical engineer because it's all
done with electricity you saw these bold
flights around here they're all
batteries and capacitors and electronic
lamps and if you want to know all about
it I wrote a little book electronic
flash strobe and if you have trouble
sleeping at night and take sleeping
pills do you if you did you'd get all
the books you wouldn't need either pills
[Music]
which one of those fast speed
photographs was the most difficult
oh the ones I haven't got yet let's see
what am i working on I'm working on the
drops now I started working on them in
1934 one drops the rain and water and
stuff I'm still working on him we got a
lot of in the backroom and I got some
students working on it we're probably
working on it for another thousand years
how did you conceive of the idea how did
you put it together the at word of
William Tell him well everybody shoots
through apples so we figured well suited
to the Apple too and when I was in in
the Switzerland I used that as a calling
card my Apple with a hole in it every
Swiss he's given us a card like it his
eyes light up in about 100 carat lamps
ladies picture at what speed was it
taken a million less than a millionth of
a second one millionth of a second yeah
it's actually about a third of a
millionth of a second I ordered the
10,000 I was gonna give everybody here
one but they didn't come you know these
some reason I know they're probably in a
subway or somewhere
if you want one call me up my secretary
was in you know tomorrow all you wanna
do if you want an apple with a hole in
it and the roller goes in one side in
this places out then it comes out the
other side with another nice big fluff
that's what they're trying to make in
that thing ever they took a that's an
atom bomb coming out of that one did you
see it
so what's what's the next step after all
this work in I gotta get rested up I'm
retired didn't you know that for the
students that are following in your
footsteps working in this field where we
are they going what type of photography
will they be working with their father
is an expert with making prints and
making photos gus kfs they're his kids
they can learn everything from him and
I'll shine him real far I don't know how
will the technology of photography be
when they're of age I have any idea and
I don't want to influence them you know
they're the younger generation we want
to leave it pure for them we don't want
to mess it all up for them do we a lot
of things I can't do I just say push
that over that's for the next generation
and that puts it takes it off of me
because I'm
retired and of course I get in that but
gonna say you've accomplished
accomplished a great deal already and
even since retirement I believe a little
bit and I enjoy what I'm doing I think
that's the important thing
and in this field is also many things to
do it's just fantastic
and you asked me what it is well I don't
know cuz tomorrow I never plan anything
well I'm more going drops right now if
you want to see little drops there in
the back room yeah have you got this on
TV well come on and I'll show you those
drops going uphill you ever see a drop
go up well you let's get out of here
let's go down go down this way and see
the drops going uphill
[Music]
that baby now you want this water to go
up good luck
come on over again where are you down
how is that doing that magic no there's
a strobe here which is why you see 60
times a second and the water is being
pumped 60 times a second what I'm seeing
is actually an illusion then it's caused
by the stress the drops are coming 60
times a second and the places if they
come sick sometimes they can drop those
things bill that's a stroll principle
and we exploit the heck out of it
these places here only a few minutes of
a second in my wanting link so the drops
from their flash are stopped maybe keep
stopping them over and over at exact
same place they look like come on drop
it looks like once you're lucky what
other applications are there professor
oh there's so many it's like saying
what's a microscope cook for just look
at everything small
what's a strobe good for look at
anything that moves everything moves
fast you can't see it the human eyes
know that at all if I turn the stove off
on this thing you can't see any that's
discussion nothing your eyes are
marvelous but they're no good for
anything that moves
interesting about tenant per second and
this is will be 60 times a second there
60 drops a second coming out of it and
you and I can't tell it go with a strobe
and then Janine work you've got to know
what's going on so you find out all
these things that are happening in fast
world the faster it goes the better it
is for us I saw something that you would
have enjoyed this morning it was a
videotape a camera that took frames at
2,000 per second I just made by Kodak
and I was amazed they showed an
explosion and then stopped it along
they're thinking four times longer with
high-speed that's sorry that's what
we work on here all the time how to get
things so it must be a principle taken
from your work uh well taking pictures
already speed yeah but there are lots of
ways to do it
thanks for coming in I can get you to
stick around turn this on and off
and you show that you're like yeah are
you gonna try it's very actinic light
yeah there there's gonna film out there
at that
and he wanted to go the other way
yeah
this table appear a little bit too short
go to eat more but six breeding yeah
Willie gets to shoot and then you can
play with all you wanna forget your
chair here so you can climb up we can go
up down put your finger in there like
you did before make it
no doubt between the drop yeah what do
you can't do but I can push this up it
makes you dropped over clean I miss each
other down so they hit each other making
a little bit sideways you get wet this
is foreseen die in here
there's another one there oh we're very
very good be around you
we worked with grips all the time about
me later this month everything through
the air for me
[Music]
[Applause]
dimmer picture
I put the film in this thing so I'm
using this brown dress
right now
okay okay waters on it off it's ready
okay time cycles
camera
the air pressures were a little slow and
get me wrong by fine okay
thirty cycles
do things on
okay all set
ready
you only get one under this right okay
big R big R
okay turn off the lights
okay dry morning
okay ready prizes I gave you about 25
feet of film and got 17 or 18 turns okay
how many Michael Ferris you want on this
machine believe it no no okay
got my motor plugin
my motor planning yeah
you gonna watch me I'm watching you
okay pump on when you see the light go
soy
okay
[Music]
there you go
have any more chips in there no more
chips goodbye
it's ready
are you trying to a Peter well I think
we got it just about right this time
because of the alignment that's better
and this is wider so we'll get more of a
field when they drop brakes up we won't
have as much data areas we haven't had
in the past okay I like your idea of
adding this to centimeter wire here
because then we have a way of looking at
the size of the drops as they as they
fall and as they break up in the field
and timing lights there and that should
work just fine so we'll have an idea of
what the film speed is all right so when
I start up if we're rocky the event will
occur in this space and we'll be able to
see the drops is there as they're
breaking into the first driver yeah and
if those guys that I've been reading
about or right
then what we should observe is the drop
sort of flexing over and then breaking
up through the middle and forming a
bubble and bursting so I think we should
go with it I think the fan pressure is
just about right to do this all right
okay you ready I'm ready let's go
okay everything's on okay go
ready look like you got it well let's
look about the film you see a happy
alright
I'll film you you got it or not I was
there okay put her in the soup
anytime don't know why Speer got it
fixed clear they are now which is a
front editors probably the blackest one
back this point there's no pictures of
that there it starts over tear this
piece off throw it away and sign that to
wake back with thanks a lot
now our onus always find where the drops
come
we've got a more uniform exposure with
that heavier diffusers
it's carbon paper later in your movie
see down there
we need those though to tell us what's
bigger honey many frames between 20-40
how are you doing this is it's 1200
frames a second
I've seen you drop are you
I'll slow by getting that cup out of
there Peter 10 to the second there's a
hundred pictures some drops are yet
yeah
where you guys out
here we are here we go
20 bucks that's where they started right
there let me feed you 140 thanks and
come give me about three three feet well
how about you are you
we have to examine these with a
magnifier sure and the axle who
eventually largeman stop all the day
that information will be in these report
1200 pictures a second going by he's
dropped it probably see it a long time
you gotta select your hype over explain
it I was pleased
I'll move it over the water so there
long enough to get the - emotions it's
the ratio emotions what I post weekly
this is a shot we made just before
we widen the deal a little bit to get a
little better picture she's putting
scratches on here
awesome movies too but we haven't caught
up with it or if you like this film is
this very fine grain so it's tremendous
amount of detail in the pictures going
all over sixty millimeter it's big now
we're gonna take it out and hang it up
on
[Applause]
we cut line
Hey
[Applause]
that baby yeah yeah I'm anybody
Oh camera all right turn it on let's go
it still looks like a fin shaped reality
a thing it's a film that's being blown
off the edge yeah never since the start
of the shape cares who cares
I can't you're trying to make it look
like that guy's picture in their book
but doesn't I'm gonna do with it okay
all right so here it comes all right
yeah look at that
BAM is that what happened to I think it
was blowing out through the middle
anyway so you trying to say that that
little drop popped it yeah probably
okay so so that secondary top is coming
off falling right down through the
center to the home of the drop but
notice the secondary bubble were forming
around the outside we're here yeah on
the other side okay yeah and that comes
up yeah and you're blue then it tries to
envelop tries to form a full bubble but
somehow it's no keep going keep going
knots break away into small drops right
dude and now what's the situation -
nothing yeah well these others the air
is being pulled down so the velocity not
enough to break these others up so we
can we can get a velocity reading but
wait a minute look at the distance
between that second drop yeah look at
that yeah that means so these are
pulling up okay no it's not continue to
happen okay let's look at the next part
down
no now now they seem to be fairly
regular here mother that's because the
air is going down with them yeah but now
look at this one coming in here that's
alright that's the way it is okay
so I'm gonna sit here I'm gonna run it
back run back get dressed okay so here
comes the drop falling through the field
- BAM now now look at the space in
between these other drums and what's
going on there now let's look at that
again don't put your hand in there okay
it's firstly you died you don't hurt you
[Music]
but your eyes can't tell it your eyes
are look good for anything the moves
fast this pump is moving 60 times a
second let's see it move - it's actually
pumping 60 times a second yeah and then
it makes the dropper come on I watch it
oh hey I don't the wait
you ready turn a knob makes the
difference it wasn't hard to do it oh my
god it's pretty image it is pretty it
just made me famous squirts it squirts
too hard the Warner's already there - it
don't let you down did you make it out
faster slower you're like yeah
yeah we get a lot of miles I know I've
seen your photographs of miles now you
you fellas since you've been so
cooperative you got a prize that's the
way I'll make applesauce back here at
MIT we don't recommend it
we don't recommend it
yeah applesauce goes all over the place
what's a cart cart yes I recognize men
shout through yeah let's
that's sooner now in the back is just
grab some mathlete
does that look like it out the light on
pretty little snowflake surface-tension
say pulling it together back to extreme
again it does I gave a lecture in a
college spike east tonight hook this
pump up backwards
my first plugs in a squirt water all
over me and the students enjoyed it
[Music]
plenty room right around here come on in
we're just trying to help out here join
these Rolo Thanks when you show the
light on it yeah
well the surface tensions boiling this
appears it's a circle yeah and the edge
of it is myself the edge of it just
pulled by surface tension in the drums
and then it gets into drops down here
this is really pretty down here but it's
not coherent each time is different so
at the top here each one is exactly the
same so you got a nice strong Emmy
it shows the details of little drops
like a little drops of hanging in the
Lord drop and that waters they once know
how this kind of devil but you see the
ripple going right through it and when
you do it the other way you can see that
the liquid coming out of the bucket down
the bottom there it's a magic light
makes the water go backwards it's good
for ecology experiment so everybody's
worrying about the water what's a nap
cook water just keep going around the
circle cleaner
hello sandy hi thanks a lot for coming
over
yes I want you to say hello to Ellen
dicks sandy young she's gonna do some
acrobatics for the mullet place be sure
what you're gonna on the camera form I'm
gonna round the life we're gonna make a
team try to catch her in the air
would you take care you come over here
how could you do us a nice cartwheel and
land over there go tight let's do it
once I just want to watch you this time
all right go ahead
all right no come back
now this time I'm gonna place a light on
you don't mind you all right my place
white go right ahead
ready perfect now let's add get on the
camera and there's a push button on
there somewhere
drip release and use I'll say open and
then it'll start it will start take my
pictures get ready 1 2 3 open perfect
let's do it again
like all the times they have to take
these two
hello sandy I appreciate you coming on
thanks a lot say hello the Helen Ellen
Dixon's Monsieur and would you perform a
couple of cartwheels terrific we're
getting you up in the air a little bit
so when you get a picture from a local
camera and be sure to hit that corner on
there I can come down and this light I
want to see you do it for it just like
you're gonna do it so Ellen comes judge
it alright ready go ready now this time
I'm gonna fly so light on you and don't
get excited when the place on the upside
down there ignore the light ready all
right go
fine now we're going to make it more
difficult we're gonna turn out all the
lights
so the strobe lights will take over and
Ellen is going over and man the camera
or lady the camera and aim it at you and
she's gonna open the shutter up on both
when I say go and then we'll let the
light go flash place let's try it now
will the lights on once more already
perfect now somebody turn out the lights
we'll make it difficult and it'll take a
little time to open that door so we get
a little light in here I can't see
anything
no more little more
all right now go ahead get ready 1 2 3 4
5 6 perfect
now Ellen you've got your finger on that
button all right I want to put it on
bulb and open the shutter when I say
open and then
we'll take a picture a series of
pictures of her on the film get ready
open perfect okay let's try it again
wind up the film Ellen set your camera
on bulb
you're all set ready go fine
Purvi all right turn on the lights now
that's all this is a mullet
here we go ball open perfect okay let's
turn on the lights now wind up your film
will develop those and we hope we can we
have it on preserve it for posterity I
hope we got a real good picture we put
it promised me you'll put on a wall okay
okay okay and if not try it again
someday
okay and the good luck in your big
contest with a Coast Guard you want to
show those poor kids up that give him a
hard time okay
I say bow open it up go oh okay okay
night was it
[Music]
here we go
can you swim - can you dive I'll bet to
get most people cowboy ready to go to
diving and swimming
we've got a nice pool that I have boys
all right
are we getting ready for this this epic
that's what they call up movies you
ready
don't waste too much Philip should be on
okay right
good
this lay this I'm going to start to
select you off come on in there's no
seat slips the floor you I've sit on the
floor that's all right
it's steam-heated floor well there's the
chair there's one over there Ellie come
on in come on Ian come on Ian
I'm going to start this lecture off by
reading a personal letters all right you
would you mind reading other people's
with Neal this is addressed to the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
comma art period question mark and there
you got it down where you know where
everybody writes in they want to a list
of catalogs and stuff you know you got
about a hundred these a day asking for
something but they didn't know who the
director photography was they knew that
well the next line is inquiry on Harry
Edgerton so they sent it up to me but
it's not my letter it's dressed in but
Matthews is to take their search today
for the first time I saw worked under
Harold Edgerton splice would drop a milk
that's that thing up there it's been
around since 1936 so when Adele was this
lady been all these years and I want to
see more I'm very excited with this
photograph I wonder about this Manny's
work is a possible what's all I do is
yeah you tell what I'm doing it's no
problem
now the next line is the is the text of
this sermon you're gonna hear today
please tell me all you know and how I
can learn more
[Music]
where's this letter from it's from a
young lady in Austin Texas any of you
ever been to Austin Texas two of you
yeah well anyway the next she says
please send books or car catalogues
articles so forth the next line I
thought I enjoyed very much I hope he is
still alive I read he was born in
nineteen three and I might have missed
him I hope not photography we do this
put a lot of information on the same
picture and let me tell you some of the
technical problems if the if the golfer
has white pants then you photograph his
pants about ten times in one position so
a first thing to do is you catch the
golfer and you wrap him up in black
velvet I find right off quick you can't
wrap his head up he has to have a head
stick out when you hit about 40 you have
to do so that's his head and now the
club you painted white and you use a
black velvet background and you cross
lights so it's you illuminate it from
the side you get the picture and then
you can run the strobe at a hundred
times a second and you can measure the
velocity of how he starts and how he
hits it you mage the lights of the club
for it it's the ball measure the
velocity of the club after it hits the
ball let's watch some energy you measure
the velocity of the ball and you're
gonna even give the golfer information
you the slightest bit interested in such
as the velocity of these tea
Oh Gussie Moran she doesn't want to wear
that black velvet gown she just got this
fancy costume on so I was okay Gussie
but if the thing up in the air where it
won't be against your your dress see so
it's up there there's the tennis ball
going up coming down being hit on its
way and I'll let you figure out how are
you arrange so that the ball is exactly
there and comes down the exactly there
when they hit it let's see your own
problem for the day now this picture
illustrates that you've it you're in
trouble see the illumination is right
then there's too much action and you
can't tell what's going as a tennis
racket there and a ball here
that's everything is wrong so I want sir
this negative in the wastebasket but I
didn't make a print of it if you want to
see that print it's down in the Museum
of Modern Art on the wall now this
picture was made in the Boston Garden of
a pole-vaulter going over
to check out the decks
Hey look who seems slide on the ice that
they landed slit Sufis Ahmad see that's
why the guy in that beautiful Drake they
say we know you're a foreigner it
sometimes gets a ride that thing and
he's got a nice boat and I rode all the
way across once for the nice boat ride
honest unsecured on all the things like
skates
[Music]
okay we're those things slide when they
land they just slide on the ice
thanks Bart she covers up there yeah
okay yeah
I was easy operation
[Music]
MOS stuff while the light is good we
don't need